how's it going bros my name is I'm a bit
sick today so it'll be a great episode
but the show must go on but boy oh boy
do we have an amazing set of items today
I bet you were thinking there's no way
that can be more weird stuff online oh
there is it never ends it never ends
the first item I have no idea where this
I just randomly buy stuff and I guess I
forgot what I bought the hope we're
gonna discover this together it's
definitely something inflatable
I would looked at it yet okay
all right it's definitely why why did I
buy this why did I buy this so creepy
okay I guess a how are your new friend
nothing use me come on man give me you
have a dried crack cocaine [ __ ] you all
right you know what the next item is for
you Edgar
what you can finally got something for
me if you've seen this show every
[ __ ] episode Edgar ends up biting one
of these items so I bought this just for
you I dare so you can buy it's a pet toy
bite it seriously if you don't bite it
I'm gonna get pissed off do it
do it Wow I'll have a little fun you
didn't yes come on bite the right edge
damn it oh I love it so much girls thank
you
there it is another fail item but the
next item is for you if you ever feel
down if you ever had a bad day you can
just get this item and you'll finish it
you can just get this item up and you'll
be happy again [ __ ] sake oh my god oh
my god I can't believe I'm doing this on
their next like this is worse than all
items combined can't even [ __ ] put it
on fantastic that looks great
do I look cute
this is not what you want tumbler Jesus
Christ try so hard to make tumblr happy
they don't understand they promised me I
would look like a cubed Fox now what the
[ __ ] is this the fourth item has been
suggested by you bros so many times it's
lipstick oh I just got it
lipstick and which is a penis shaped
lipstick this show really went downhill
fast didn't it obviously I'm gonna have
to try it on but here's how it looks
like nice very nice huh I almost don't
want don't won't do this like I'll do
pretty much anything I don't know why
I'm stopping I'm even hesitating here
but [ __ ] man
so
like I'm not homophobic but stroking a
[ __ ] fake penis around my lips just
doesn't feel right to me I'm sorry but
man oh man do I look fabulous welcome to
- PewDiePie channel we do the [ __ ] then
that anyone else have integrity not to
do this one is my favorite so I bet you
were thinking I don't think this video
can become any more weird well well well
it's another nipple cover we've done
these before no big deal let me just put
them on nice
then the final item is a hat oh okay I
get it
let me just try it on then I know you'll
see it how do I look
I guess you can store your fruit here or
something I don't know this [ __ ] am i
doing that was it for this video I don't
know why this one was really humiliating
especially the nipple stuff you know
what let's take them on oh thank god
they go off easy
the internet is strong with this one all
right price I'm gonna have to end that
episode there if you in [ __ ] sake you
go ahead and hit that like button share
with your friends family let the people
know about the good word of pills I'm
gonna go watch this dick off my face and
I'll see you in the next one as always
stay awesome British this is how I
schoolgirl
do you like it